I have my literal business marketing
degree that put me in a
cute $80,000 in
debt and I make more serving sushi rolls
cuz I was I've been applying to
marketing jobs for weeks now and the the
pay cut is
insane insane but the jobs that are like
aute 150 to 200,000 a year I'm not
getting those I'm a 20 almost
25-year-old my birthday soon almost
25-year-old chick going against you know
corporate ass America people with so
much experience all I got is my degree
you know people say get your degree but
then they don't talk about how you need
experience the degree was the experience
have you made 200 Grand ever have the
vast majority of people ever made
$200,000 let alone at 25